at Apple we believe in a future without
wires and this belief drove the design
of our new totally wireless fully
connected product the airbag thanks to a
combination of the most advanced folded
paper technology and Apple's new w1 chip
Apple has the power to deliver the
world's most intelligent bag infrared
motion sensors and accelerometers
automatically detect moisture weight and
fullness and can wirelessly deliver your
airbag status to all of your connected
Apple devices the airbag provides up to
three hours of use on a single charge
and the airbag fits your lifestyle in a
number of ways as a grocery carrying
device a cat home
Rosy's mask a bag hutch and a receptacle
for disposing your obsolete Apple
products the air bag comes equipped with
standard five pound capacity for a
larger capacity the air bag plus and the
ultra portable air bag mini and
introducing the future of wireless the
air part bag a completely handle free
shopping bag
we don't even know what you want anymore
[Applause]
you